hello welcome to see you playing Carol M
to FM what's your name ok so we've got a
rentier opening ready gambit 30 Bishop
to f5 yeah this kind of ending has been
played a lot over the years and why does
a but it's very slightly better it's not
much but its its load something so can I
go pee should be three right away I
haven't put the bishop on g2 yet I
wonder maybe he can play yeah I'm not
really threatening to take after your 5
for example I should've thought about
that a bit yeah bad move I think he can
go we five maybe not I don't know but ok
so if he takes now all is good back to
this sound as a move down
it's actually interesting takes takes c6
a heavy for one takes it takes it and a
six Hanks interesting so maybe Bishop g7
is better yeah he went for it hmm yeah
let's go F for him make it more
difficult for him to play five okay
didn't go for that and maybe Bishop c5
actually I'm not sure how d4 helps me
yeah I should have thought about this a
bit more Bishop c5 now okay I can't go
deform but i'm not into the astok about
it what else does he have
and taking a long time so light you form
but I just have bishops you one I want
to go there anyway I mean it's not bad
it's not a totally bad idea we should
you wanted an e-form
alright on your end buddy yeah he's
still let sorry for the sound kicking my
paper bin here ok so i might as well
drink some water hmm yeah ok here i can
also go e for maybe a t4d for him ok and
so let's push that away then you form
thats gain space takes Knight takes that
link 926
and the bishop on f1 is on the rocks
there mmm that looks very awkward for
black okay interesting one I still have
96 if i play b 3 what is he doing
check oh I didn't see that one didn't
see that one coming so d5 and I can
check what you can go to e7 and if I go
96 King e7 is probably I can go to this
six though hmm ok
h6 is also interesting n t5 to take on
b6 okay I mean I will probably just win
on time you anyway but I'd like to find
some kind of decent solution from from a
very good position check yeah Knight c3
year what's my thought it's not sure how
good it actually is ah didn't see that
move it all it's very simple but it
still didn't see it so
he might have defo here by the way and
we are he answered yes then oh and night
f2 is a threat oh my god let screwed up
I screwed it up
and I moving on time but I said just I
just didn't play it right check
black for fence on time Ja now it's very
often happens if you know you're going
to win 0 on time you kind of you can of
yeah you're not a nut shop anymore so um
yeah this was kind of okay white is
better not winning but better and tap to
this long castling wins yeah it's not
once you see it it makes perfect sense
you have to play night bc 3 and then d 5
by pushing everything open it's
completely winning this is the engines
line yeah this is pretty awful okay
interesting so let's see um I went here
and this is not a good movie a c5 here
the computer confirms what I was
thinking because I simply didn't I
didn't really think this through because
I cannot take now here the bishop is
completely off side after you should
before black is threatening this yeah he
missed that opportunity now everything
is good again right here and now effort
to control more of the center the
computer just wants to play Bishop g2
maybe gap first attack the d5 pawn
certainly make some sense but this also
feels like a decent move now chief for
Bishop c5 yeah and now I get this and we
get to the critical position yeah this
is wasn't just good night ec3 is
indicated by the computer
okay the computer wants to play this and
now castling long yeah this d5 move is
going to be extremely strong in this is
what the engine is giving and white is
in very good shape yeah and the chosen
this isn't all that good yeah it really
isn't this night a4 is too good but I
didn't find it and this is all of a
sudden leading check leading to wild
complications I've got 95 yeah position
is still slightly better for white
according to the engine check but as so
if it still felt to me like I've screwed
it up um yeah he has issues at this this
is still kind of trapped and this is
also not safe the computers line is this
look III you just kind of funky takes
bishop jakes you should be too yeah
that's a funky ending yeah computer
gives wyd an advantage and I kind of
agree but this is like playing the
lottery with no time okay I want it
thanks for watching